et benjamin sont gérés par des témoins
femme en mariage il a fait envoyer un
seul but la dernière non et s'il a été
plus rapide que toi
à la prochaine n ont pas la prochaine
fois sur massa spécial gaffe
alors non ça s'est fait tout
naturellement au moment où tu m'épouser
on amour que j'aime et comment où et
comment au match de foot à paris alors
on n'est pas gps à auchan ben non non
aux gens des choses à voir aux
chandelles avec tdf boîte
oui mon passé mais surtout c'est une
boîte on va à dire prêter boîtes
échangistes et sachez que trop de
lumière
[Rires]
c'était à paris très vite et nous il n'y
a pas de scénario restant chez toi que
chez moi chez moi chez moi j'étais jolie
car tu te souviens pas dans la base
nature une demande alors comment pas
demander l'avis aux mariages terre
d'islam en moi comme ça ça parle à tout
le monde
avant l'heure c'est je crois que c'était
à portbail bombal alors pour nice et
dans la manche d'accord la plage au
coucher de soleil
quite avec vous aviez à côté mariage
enfants ils sont pourris déjà une
américaine à dunkerque butin au détail
est très beau vainqueur
oui mais ce week end à liévin castadi
quand week end à mexico et vous
quand on traite les villes j'aime pas
contre la clé non c'est bon c'est pas
glam